dilan français des élections giscard
gagne mais la victoire est loin de
simplifier les problèmes de l'opposition
déception à gauche notamment au parti
socialiste laurent fabius tête de liste
socialiste est notre invité il
s'explique
bilan européen des mêmes élections en
pointe les socialistes et les
écologistes et aussi quelques poussées
d'extrêmement
à l'assemblée opposition et gouvernement
face à face une nouvelle fois cette fois
à propos de la présidence comme une
antenne 2 fr3 la sécheresse qui continue
la situation est sérieuse dans certaines
régions mais pas catastrophique
pas encore bonsoir lendemain d'élections
européennes c'est-à-dire l'heure des
bilans le nouveau parlement des 12 sera
dorénavant un petit peu plus rose et un
petit peu plus vert alors je m'explique
sur un plan global en effet pour les 12
pays européens de la cee
les vainqueurs de ces élections sont
essentiellement les socialistes ou les
sociaux-démocrates ça c'est le côté rose
et puis aussi et ça c'est plus nouveau
les écologistes c'est le côté vert nous
allons revenir sur tout cela dans le
courant du journal est aussi sur les
enseignements politiques en france
les français n'ont pas tout à fait voter
vous allez le voir comme l'ensemble des
européens
mais voyons d'abord les résultats précis
de ces différentes listes pour le
scrutin français avec véronique sainte
olives les françaises abstentionnistes
ont battu leur propre record 51,11 %
d'abstention un français sur deux ne
s'est pas déplacé pour voter c'est
valéry giscard d'estaing qui apparaît
comme le grand vainqueur des élections
d'hier
il arrive en tête avec 28 8 % des voix
et obtient 26 sièges pour sa liste
d'union
simone veil al'inverse a perdu son pari
avec 8,4 pour cent des voix elle est en
deçà de l'objectif d'un score à deux
chiffres
elle obtient 7 sièges c'est voir ajouter
à celle de giscard n'atteignent pas 40%
alors quand 80 capes elle avait obtenu à
la tête de la liste udf rpr 43% des
suffrages jean marie le pen arrive en
troisième position
il obtient 11 7% des voix soit 10 sièges
une façon pour lui de prouver son
ancrage électoral depuis cinq ans puis
en échec pour laurent fabius 23 6% des
suffrages
22 sièges la liste socialiste n'empêche
pas les bénéfices de la popularité de
françois mitterrand les écologistes
derrière antoine waechter se confirme
comme une vraie force politique
ils obtiennent 10 5% des suffrages et 9
sièges le parti communiste lui confirme
son déclin
philippe herzog ne réunit que 7 7% des
voix 7 sièges
il recule encore par rapport aux
dernières européennes à noter enfin le
score des petites listes chasse pêche et
tradition obtient plus de 4% des voix
un pied de nez aux partis installés en
france du côté des vainqueurs il y à
valéry giscard d'estaing
il a obtenu un bon score vous l'avez vu
même si les listes des partis de droite
d'opposition comme vous voudrez c'est à
dire la liste ici car plus la liste
veille n'obtiennent pas aussi bon score
qu'aux élections européennes précédentes
et puis la victoire de vge n'a pas l'air
d'enchanter tout le monde même dans son
propre parti
l'udf olivier lerner valéry giscard
d'estaing et jacques chirac étaient
presque étonné de se retrouver côte à
côte et hier soir pour commenter à chaud
cette victoire de l'opposition sur les
socialistes pour autant rpr et udf ne
sont pas tous au garde à vous devant
leurs chefs respectifs exemple françois
léotard dans une interview qui paraîtra
demain dans le point il ne mâche pas ses
mots
la victoire de vge était nécessaire dit
il elle n'est pas suffisante pour
assurer l'avenir l'avenir tel était bien
le sujet qui réveillait les esprits
lorsque vge posait le pied quelque part
ces dernières semaines certains à droite
espérait le voir quitter la scène
politique française
mais valéry giscard d'estaing n'a pas
l'âme d'un pré retraité jacques chirac
françois léotard simone veil les
rénovateurs en sont pour leurs frais il
était temps d'apporter à la vie
politique
une encourage une moralité et surtout
une volonté de s'assumer complètement
peut-être en dehors de ces appareils et
pour s'engager dans une entreprise de
renouveau nous espérons une pensons que
cette volonté de renouveau elle existe
les français valéry giscard d'estaing a
même retrouvé ses automatismes
huit ans après sa défaite présidentielle
son grand retour pose cependant quelques
problèmes si l'on lit entre les lignes
l'union a fait sa force mais la page
risque vite d'être tournée primaire à
droite parti unique udf rpr et cds sont
encore loin de rouler pour giscard le
chef de garde devra faire attention
un train peut en cacher un autre le rpr
se félicite aussi de la victoire de la
liste giscard il a contribué à l'union
il veut
en récolter les fruits mais au rpr aussi
il y a des rénovateurs laurent boussier
renforcement de la stratégie d'union
convocation d'états généraux de
l'opposition et représentation
proportionnelle des différents courants
dans les instances du rpr jacques chirac
et les dirigeants du mouvement gaulliste
ont très rapidement tiré les leçons de
la victoire hier de valéry giscard
d'estaing et du demi-échec de la liste
de simone veil pour jacques chirac il
n'est pas question de fusion entre le
rpr et l'udf mais d'une stratégie de
l'union avec programme commun de
gouvernement et primaires pour désigner
le candidat des deux parties à la
présidence de la république à
l'intérieur du rpr les courants sont
officialisées un moyen pour la direction
de couper l'herbe sous les pieds des
rénovateurs et de michel noir avant son
heure de vérité on a appelé les
rénovateurs des différents partis
politiques sont des hommes et des femmes
qui
on dit qu'il fallait réfléchir façon
plus approfondie sur un certain nombre
de problèmes
c'est exactement ce que je souhaitais
faire c'est exactement ce qu alain juppé
l'équipe qui l'entourent ont engagé des
rénovateurs qui ont estimé cet après
midi dans un communiqué que l'union et
la rénovation était plus que jamais
nécessaire union rénovation union et
réforme des mots qui seront beaucoup
employé jeudi prochain au conseil
national du rpr jacques chirac lui a
déjeuné aujourd'hui avec valéry giscard
d'estaing
une manière pour les deux hommes de
prouver que l'union se poursuit après
les élections effectivement l'invité de
l'heure de vérité tout de suite après ce
journal c'est michel noir le maire de
lyon michel noir et rpr il a soutenu la
liste d'union
c'est giscard juppé mais ville a
accueilli simone veil dans sa ville de
lyon pendant la campagne électorale
michel noir bonsoir alors est-ce que
l'échec de la liste simone veil qui est
obtenu je rappelle un peu plus de huit
et demi pour cent des voix est ce que
c'est pas une grosse déception pour vos
amis rénovateur qui l'avaient soutenu
donc je crois que les rénovateurs avait
souhaité ne pas présenter une lisse et
d'autre part avaient souhaité que le
camp de l'opposition gagne et je dirais
que quand un français sur deux n'a pas
voté
et quand deux français sur trois n'ont
pas choisi les formations que m'ont dit
traditionnel classique de logos de
l'opposition ou de la majorité
il faut à la fois être déçus se poser
des questions ce que feront tout à
l'heure les journalistes de l'heure de
vérité bien sûr et donc il vous
interrogions qui vous pouvez aussi poser
des questions par l'intermédiaire bien
sûr de svt où se trouve geneviève moll
qui choisira sélectionnera vos questions
et les posera à michel noir
autre vainqueur de cette élection est là
la france a suivi le mouvement général
ce sont les verts les écologistes ont
marqué des points partout notamment dans
les pays de l'europe du sud
henri soyez sûr en tout cas que les
écologistes sont là bien là et qu'ils le
resteront longtemps
pas de triomphalisme tout juste un
sourire pour le verre de la victoire
c'est un peu à l'image
chef de file des écolos le succès des
verts acquis sans grand fracas
pourtant rien aux présidentielles de 88
ne laissait présager une poussée verte
de cette importance antoine waechter
obtenait alors -2 4%
encore trop peu pour pavoiser il faudra
attendre les cantonales de septembre 88
et surtout les municipales de mars
dernier pour voir le bout du tunnel
aujourd'hui les écolos dépasse les 10%
des suffrages dans 58 départements sur
96 allant parfois jusqu'à 20 % en alsace
ou en corse mais un succès cela se gère
deux difficultés majeures à régler
d'abord renouveler les 9,4 élu
aujourd'hui à strasbourg et surtout
traité avec leurs homologues
d'outre-rhin les grünen souvent plus
rouges que verts du leadership du groupe
au parlement
une place qu'il pourrait obtenir tant
leur slogan ni droite ni gauche semble
plus que jamais le gage de leur succès
côté déceptions en france toujours le
parti socialiste la liste fabius n'a pas
obtenu avec seulement je vous le
rappelle 23 6%
les résultats espérés alors au ps on ne
cache pas la déception jean-michel
ouverture la question dans un contexte
de forte popularité du président de la
république et du gouvernement
comment le ps est il pu subir une telle
désaffection de son électorat na toute
première déception dès hier soir de
michel rocard
certes la liste socialiste est en
progrès significatifs depuis les
dernières élections européennes
mais nous pouvions espérer davantage et
il faut dès lors se demander pourquoi
trop faible mobilisation du ps derrière
laurent fabius ou désintérêt des
électeurs vis-à-vis d'une europe trop
lointaine défaut de conception de la
campagne électorale ou lassitude
vis-à-vis des urnes autant de questions
qu'elles doivent maintenant répondre les
socialistes pour jacques delors il y
avait globalement un vrai problème
d'explication mais j'ai toujours pensé
que expliquer l'europe ce n'était pas
simplement la tâche de ceux qui
travaillent à bruxelles c'est aussi la
tâche des gouvernements qu'est-ce que ça
n'est pas un échec des européens non à
l'échelle de la france
on c'est un échec de la classe politique
française cette eau et environnement
un jugement qui ne doit pas laisser
indifférent
laurent fabius effectivement je vous le
disais en titre laurent fabius est notre
invité bonsoir monsieur fabius alors cet
échec des socialistes vous le prenez
comme en com justement un échec des
socialistes ou un échec personnel de
laurent fabius
j'assume le choix n'avait pas l'habitude
de rejeter sur d'autres j'ai pris mes
risques en acceptant l'honneur de
conduire cette liste on va en discuter
j'assume mais ce qui me fera beaucoup y
compris dans les commentaires que vous
avez fait c'est quand on parle d'échec
du côté des socialistes et de succès du
côté de la rade alors là j'avoue que
pour moi tu comprendras pourquoi quand
vous regardez les chiffres de résultats
liberty chiffres du côté de la droite
udf rpr plus simone veil
il y à une perte de huit sièges du côté
socialiste il y a un gars de deux sièges
personne ne peut contester ce chiffre
est quand on dit la droite perd 8 sièges
c'est un triomphe le parti socialiste
gagne deux sièges c'est un échec alors
je voudrais qu'on revienne à des choses
précises évidemment c'est moins que ce
que nous pouvions espérer
et c'est moins que ce que nous donner
des sondages mais il faut pas comparer
les résultats des élections au sondage
il faut comparer les résultats des
élections au résultat des élections il
n'empêche marcel de bach bizet ce matin
c'est l'hypothèse la plus basse que
présent engager les cci c'est un échec
quand les partis disent je vais être
très précis là-dessus nous progressions
en sièges ça personne ne peut le
contester
mais nous pensions d'après les sondages
toujours c'est à des sondages que nous
pourrions faire plus parce que dans les
sondages on me mettais à peu près tous
un petit peu en dessous de monsieur
giscard d'estaing bon là la réalité
c'est que si nous avons gagné en siècle
allons pas gagner autant que nous
aurions pu et que la droite elle a perdu
considérablement
donc je propose que l'on revienne au
fait que l'on doive pendant toute votre
campagne vous vous êtes un peu servi du
président de la république comme d'un
étendard le score que vous avez réalisé
ce qu'il n'a faiblit pas françois
mitterrand tu crois pas j'ai développé
de chez dargaud
on va pas refaire la campagne maintenant
ça n'a pas de sens d'abord l'importance
d'avoir une europe du progrès social et
le fait que le parlement européen
maintenant soit orienté à gauche
à mon avis va aller dans ce sens ce qui
est positif parce que ce sont les
européens notamment les français qui
vont en profiter
et puis le fait aussi que nous
soutenions l'équipe gouvernementale et
de le président mais qui ait pas
d'ambiguïté dans ce que je dis je suis
frappé comme vous par l'abstention ça
grave
je suis frappé comme vous aussi par le
fait qu' il ya une montée des
écologistes et il faut s'interroger là
dessus dans le fait de l'extrême droite
fait un score important de tout ça ce
sont justes qui mettra mais le point
principal que certains d'entre vous
souligner ou d'autres collègues consiste
à dire échec delà du parti disent alors
qu'ils gagnent des sièges et victoire de
la droite alors qu'elle en perd là
dessus je dois dire que c'est un peu le
monde à revers
puis la retraite jusqu'à allez vous
faire pour le prochain congrès du ps une
motion bien à vous pour vous positionner
ou une simple contribution pour
reprendre éventuellement date ça on a le
temps de
de voir ça parce que le congrès va voir
le je crois l'année prochaine mais la
seule chose que je puis dire là dessus
c'est la chose suivante
ces élections sont significatives quand
même ça prouve que beaucoup de gens
s'abstiennent ce qui est très
dommageable pour la démocratie
ça prouve que les partis dits
traditionnels ne recule pas la totalité
des voix tant s'en faut
ça prouve que nous vous avons une
difficulté à mobiliser notre électorat
c'était déjà le cas aux précédentes
élections européennes mais c'est encore
le cas cette fois ci ça prouve que nous
avons des difficultés à rassembler bon
toutes ces questions et bien d'autres
l'évolution de la technologie le souci
écologique l'évolution du fonctionnement
du parti
tout ça fait que sans portée critique
sur personne je trouve qu'il est normal
que nous ayons un débat dans l'unité
dans le rassemblement dans la série de
qualité mais c'est une bonne chose
d'avoir un débat mais vous laurent
fabius ou sans vous sentez affaibli par
rapport aux autres leaders socialistes
j'espère les autres écoutez en 1979
oui françois mitterrand conduisait la
liste et il avait fait le même score que
je que je vais en 1984 c'était une pente
l'optique beaucoup plus difficile
beaucoup plus difficile et le score avec
un petit peu là c'est moins que nos
espérances mais je rappelle que deux ans
après les difficultés soit 1,19
la gauche avait gagné l'élection
présidentielle alors je prends le
résultat tel qu'il est j'aurais souhaité
qu'il soit plus élevé mais je rappelle
quitte à vous lasser qu'on ne peut pas
dire qu'il y ait chèque pour ceux qui
ont gagné des sièges et succès pour ce
cas nous perdre
dernier point très vite vous aller
siéger réellement parlement phrase ou
bien sûr je vais cg et ça va commencer
dans quelques jours et je serais curieux
d'ailleurs de savoir mais vous lui posez
sûrement la question de savoir si
monsieur jusqu'à saint mathieu j'ai
aussi écouté on lui posera la question
merci laurent fabius et autres points en
france encore la stabilité de l'extrême
droite jean marie le pen et la liste du
front national obtiennent plus de 11 et
demi pour cent des voix même chose dans
d'autres pays d'europe avec une poussée
très forte de l'extrême droite en
allemagne
roland sicard
jean marie le pen s'en lèchent déjà les
becs 11 7% des voix le front national ne
réalise pas la percée qu'il espérait
mais maintient ses positions et surtout
l'extrême droite décroche la troisième
place sur l'échiquier politique français
un résultat qui en deux mois de campagne
où jean marie le pen est revenue sans
cesse sur le thème de l'immigration
qu'ils analysent maintenant à l'échelon
européen
je crois que des pays comme l'italie par
exemple comme l'espagne qui était
relativement très différents comme la
grèce se rendent compte maintenant que
la poussée la pression démographique qui
s'exerce en direction de l'europe ne
vise pas seulement certains pays
privilégiés comme la france qu'elle
constitue le fait principal de la
géopolitique de la fin du siècle et du
début du troisième millénaire
et de fait l'extrême droite marque des
points dans d'autres pays stabilité en
italie et surtout percer en allemagne où
les républicains de l'ancien de la
waffen ss franz schubert rafle 7% des
voix sur des positions très proches de
celles du front national
l'europe des patries ne sommes pas des
anti européen explique-t-il
ce serait une absurdité et ce que nous
voulons c'est des flandres à notre
manière
l'intérêt national dix députés en france
quatre en italie 6 en allemagne
peut-être en belgique le groupe des
droites européennes renforce ses
positions parlement de strasbourg
un groupe dont jean-marie le pen devrait
être à nouveau le président alors voilà
pour les faits résumant tout cela si
vous voulez bien avec vous jean louis le
spen les enseignements de ce scrutin
eh bien quoi qu'en dise jacques delors
c'est avant tout un échec pour l'europe
dans tous les pays où le vote n'est pas
obligatoire et particulièrement en
france
le parti des abstentionnistes n'a fait
qu'augmenter son score par rapport aux
scrutins précédents
on a beau dire on a beau faire le rêve
du grand marché européenne 93 ne
provoque aucun engouement chez nos
concitoyens au moment où françois
mitterrand s'apprête à prendre les rênes
de la communauté pour six mois
ce n'est guère flatteur deuxième désaveu
celui des formations politiques
traditionnelles
les trois grands partis du gouvernement
rpr udf et ps ne rassemble qu'un peu
plus de la moitié des suffrages exprimés
ce qui ne représente
un quart de l'électorat c'est bien
maigre giscard plus veille ne font pas
mieux que veille tout seul en 84 et
fabius ne résiste pas à l'érosion
pour quelqu'un qui s'est réclamé pendant
toute sa campagne du président de la
république ça fait plutôt mauvais effet
troisième des aveux de l'électorat
français
si on additionne les résultats de toutes
les petites listes aux bons scores
confirment et de jean marie le pen et à
celui exceptionnels obtenus par les
verts on arrive à la conclusion suivante
plus de 30% de ceux qui ont pris la
peine d'aller voter hier ne sont pas
représentés à l'assemblée nationale se
dire qu'il ya depuis hier un vrai
problème de représentativité délectera
qu'il faudra bien résoudre un jour sans
doute en insufflant un peu de
proportionnelle dans le scrutin
majoritaire pour les élections
législatives
aujourd'hui pratiquement tous les partis
politiques en conviennent même s'ils ne
l'avouent pas toujours explicitement
merci jean louis dit en tout cas
maintenant nous sommes à l'heure des
bilans
nous pouvons voir à quoi va ressembler
le nouveau parlement européen
même si la constitution des groupes au
parlement ne sera faite au mois de
juillet alors si vous le voulez bien des
sinon le fromage c'est le mot que nous
employons toujours lorsqu'on veut
représenter par un défunt les parts que
s'attribuent les différents partis
rachid arhab voici ce que pourrait être
le nouveau parlement européen un fromage
comme l'on dit qu'ils ne sera définitif
que dans quelques jours un fromage qui
va se faire grignoter par une petite
souris verte
les écologistes français pourrait en
effet former un groupe avec les belges
et les italiens notamment mais peut-être
sans les grünen allemands jugés trop
rouge et sans les verts anglais écarté
du parlement malgré un score de 14%
les verts seront donc en position
d'arbitré dans l'hémicycle en effet si
le groupe socialiste progresse fortement
il n'a pas la majorité à lui seul et
cela malgré la percée des travaillistes
anglais est certainement le renfort des
communistes italiens qui pourrait
s'inscrire au groupe socialiste à
l'extrême droite
l'événement vient d'allemagne où les
corbeaux du groupe républicain n'ont pas
l'intention de lâcher le pro maj qu'ils
viennent de prendre à droite recule des
démocrates-chrétiens rfa chute des
conservateurs en espagne l'euro droite
est dit
percée en résumé donc les trois
nouvelles couleurs du parlement européen
seront le rose le vert et le noir
socialistes écologistes et extrême
droite feront certainement beaucoup
parler d'eux dans les prochains jours
ici à strasbourg strasbourg où les
tractations commencent dès aujourd'hui
pour la création des futurs groupes
politiques du parlement européen
des tractations qui dureront au moins
jusqu'à la mi juillet puisque ce n'est
que dans un mois que le parlement
européen reprendra ses travaux un tour
de quelques capitales maintenant nous
allons aller dans celles où il ya eu des
résultats surprenants ou spectaculaire
c'est le cas par exemple à londres à
bonn et à athènes athènes où d'ailleurs
il y avait en même temps des élections
législatives alors voyons tout cela dans
l'ordre avec nos envoyés spéciaux
ici à londres maria thatcher reconnaît
elle même que le résultat de ces
élections européennes est décevant
la déroute est certes moins sévère que
prévu mais c'est la première défaite en
15 ans du premier ministre britannique
la fota qui a elle-même répond nombre de
ses amis sa vision d'une europe minimale
sa manière de gouverner le retour de
l'inflation tout cela a été sanctionné
en vrac
désormais les travailler pour le vent en
poupe leur leaders ni kinnock à la
capacité de succéder à mme lynch
quant au score des verts plus de 15%
c'est presque incroyable car ils
viennent de nulle part
cela dit à cause du scrutin majoritaire
les verts ne seront pas représentés à
strasbourg en république d'irlande le
premier ministre charles koffi avait
convoqué des élections générales
anticipées pour obtenir une majorité
absolue
peine perdue il conduira à nouveau un
gouvernement minoritaire
ces européennes ont été d'abord un
camouflet pour les chrétiens démocrates
du chancelier kohl qui n'a même plus la
majorité avec sa coalition
gouvernementale les voix qu'il a perdu
son talent et à l'extrême droite
ce credo de ce code est une lourde
défaite mais pas question de s'allier
aux verts ou à cette extrême droite
comme les républicains qui ont joué sur
la peur de la communauté européenne ou
sur l'arrivée des réfugiés du
tiers-monde fait le grand dole
si les socialistes ont pavoisé et danser
c'est qu'il comptait mieux faire mais le
spd perd deux sièges
seuls les libéraux de monsieur ganger un
parti clé pour gouverner se réjouissent
vraiment ils reviennent au parlement
européen
mais en cas d'élection générale aucune
coalition n'aurait aujourd'hui la
majorité
athènes une concentration de plus de
quatre millions d'habitants
il y a deux ans la canicule et la
pollution tue plusieurs centaines de
personnes depuis l'écologie a gagné ici
du terrain au point de presque emporté
un siège de député européen
de fait les députés grecs de strasbourg
serait parti sans surprise entre la
droite et la gauche mais avantage à la
droite car c'est bien elle qui sort
grand vainqueur de ce double scrutin les
élections nationales ont vu s'affronter
ici deux septuagénaires aux aventures
galantes largement étalé dans la presse
ces constantes amis de takis le leader
de la nouvelle démocratie qui a gagné
fait de la droite la première force
politique du pays
les socialistes sont battus dans les
urnes mais aussi par les scandales
financiers
andréas papandréou a durablement écoeuré
une partie du pays
la grèce vient d'entrer en instabilité
politique le parlement penche vers une
droite dont le leader vient de proposer
une alliance contre nature aux
communistes
andréas papandréou pourrait plus
logiquement faire de même pour durer
devant tant de convoitises
la nouvelle gauche communiste répète
qu'elle veut avant toute discussion
une véritable épuration de la classe
politique grecque
dernier coup d'oeil sur les européennes
et nous en termineront par là pour
aujourd'hui le score surprenant obtenu
par la liste les listes des chasseurs et
pêcheurs en france +2 4%
c'est beaucoup même si cette liste a été
parfois le refuge de toutes sortes de
mécontentement sans rapport avec la
lutte avec le lièvre ou avec le goujon
bruno roger petit les chasseurs nous y
serons pas le drapeau blanc se sentant
encerclé par des écologistes de plus en
plus puissants il contre attaque et bat
maintenant la campagne électorale
résultat 4 % des voix ont été débusqués
aux élections européennes et fleuron du
tableau de chasse la somme la gironde
les landes des départements où plus de
14% des voix sont tombés dans
l'escarcelle des chasseurs
mais attention s'il aime la chasse il
affirme aussi mener le même combat que
les écologistes
de toute façon c'est à peu près la même
chose nous luttons pour la même clause
de sauvegarde a donc dans la pure et
dans la plupart des cas et bien c'est la
même c'est la même guerre qui continuent
d'ailleurs la préservation du gibier les
palombes girondine les autres
tourterelles landaise n'ont qu'à voler
plus haut il existe désormais un jeune
chasseur un vote très protestataires
émis par une corporation qui s'estiment
en état de siège rebelles aux directives
de communautés européennes qui limite
leur droit de chasse et si vous chercher
chez nous c'est pas 3% entre des
écologistes entrant parlement européen
pour y défendre la nature et des
chasseurs qui n'est même pas l'europe
l'affrontement promet d'être rude je lis
tu vas pas nous avait réussi le reste de
l'actualité maintenant et tout d'abord
la chaleur inutile de mettre les points
sur les i nous avons tous transpirer
aujourd'hui dans deux jours c'est l'été
le beau temps dure depuis maintenant si
longtemps que le spectre de la
sécheresse
ray apparaît alors va-t-on vivre la même
expérience qu'en 76 bien pour l'instant
nul ne peut le dire mais en tout cas la
situation est loin d'être catastrophique
le point tout de suite
véronique auger pas de bateau sur cette
partie du canal du midi
l'eau est réservé à l'irrigation de
quarante mille hectares de cultures en
haute garonne la marine vient alimenter
en eau l'île de groix en bretagne le
barrage local s'essouffle faute de pluie
se sont pour l'instant les deux seuls
exemples de véritable pénurie en france
pas de quoi crier au feu mais gare
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour
retrouver une sécheresse comme en 1976
voici la situation au nord-est d'une
ligne quand briand sent pas de problème
sauf exceptions locales en 76 c'est
cette région qui était la plus touchée
le centre lui manque déjà 250 mm d'eau
par rapport aux normes saisonnières
le sud connaît un déficit de 200 mm
actuellement nous sommes dans une phase
d'élaboration de mesures préventives et
palliative
déterminant nous faisons l'inventaire
des zones à risques des zones
potentiellement point noir du point de
vue de la sécheresse où seuls les
préfets des départements concernés ont
constitué des cellules de crise qui
définissent ces mesures palliatives et
préventif pour le cas où mais pour le
moment il est très prématuré de crier au
secours de toute façon il sera difficile
de contenter tout le monde cet été où il
fera chaud et les agriculteurs se
plaindront où il pleuvra et les
vacanciers j'aime iron man lille bête
palme est la veuve de l'ancien premier
ministre suédois olof palme est
assassiné en 86 a formellement reconnu
le meurtrier de son mari
il s'agit d'un suédois de 42 ans qui est
jugé en ce moment même à stockholm il
nie toute participation au crime
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
importantes de ce jour avec ce soir des
étapes en pologne en chine et en
belgique
eric guérin
succès de solidarité confirmée au second
tour des élections législatives en
pologne le syndicat raflent tous les
sièges réservés à l'opposition sauf un
ce deuxième tour a été marqué par un
taux de participation très faible en
particulier dans les provinces où seuls
les candidats du parti communiste
étaient en lice
alors que l'armée quadrillent toujours
les rues de pékin dix nouvelles
personnes ont été arrêtées aujourd'hui
en chine ce qui porte officiellement à
1200 le nombre d'arrestations depuis les
événements du 4 juin selon une agence
américaine les autorités chinoises ont
reporté à une date ultérieure
la session extraordinaire du congrès qui
devait débuter demain pour discuter des
réformes à mettre en place
nouveaux affrontements entre forces de
l'ordre et mineurs en belgique ces
derniers se diriger vers le parlement et
le palais royal à bruxelles pour
protester contre la fermeture des deux
dernières mines belge quelques 2500
policiers les en ont empêchés il y
aurait eu au moins 16 blessés surface
cette information en provenance d'union
soviétique il y a eu des morts et des
blessés ce week-end au cours d'émeutes
au kazakhstan en asie centrale
selon l'agent stas de ce soir les
émeutes de ce week-end dans la ville de
novi ou zen ont fait des morts et des
blessés sans autre précision peugeot
augmente le prix de ses voitures malgré
les recommandations du ministre de
l'économie toutes les peugeot
augmenteront de 2,25 pour cent au 1er
juillet depuis un an le prix des peugeot
aura donc plus augmenté que l'inflation
discussion à l'assemblée nationale sur
l'audiovisuel il s'agit du projet de loi
du gouvernement qui prévoit une
présidence commune pour antenne 2 et fr3
un projet qui est contestée vous le
savez même parfois par certains
socialistes mais je la prends un instant
michel rocard le premier ministre a
décidé d'utiliser la procédure du 49-3
pour faire adopter ce projet de loi
compte rendu d'audience à l'assemblée
compte rendu de l'assemblée pardon parce
qu'albi mission révolution tranquille au
palais bourbon gardes républicains et
député en manque de repères assemblée en
chantier pour cause de qui s'en tenaient
en six jours anniversaires le
gouvernement menace puis sort le 49-3
présidence comme une antenne 2 fr3 le
président du csa lui même s'est dit
réservé l'opposition elle aujourd'hui
n'a cessé de crier son veto je vois la
volonté de faire partir les deux
présidents quelques mois avant leur
terme
ça me semble l'art de l'artillerie
lourde pour pas grand chose
on va avoir un président qui va essayer
de tout régenter donc il va y avoir il
ya un risque d'abus de position
dominante
au fond on voit reprocher aux futures
présidences que la gauche peut reprocher
à monsieur r sens il ya il ya quelques
années dans la presse
communistes eux non plus n'ont pas caché
leur hostilité l'idée qui est derrière
aussi c'est de recentraliser afin
d'avoir la mainmise plus complètes sur
l'information le gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'avait pas le choix
le premier ministre arrivé in extremis
vient tout juste de trancher dans le vif
engagement de responsabilité coupe les
parlementaires le débat n'ira donc pas
jusqu'à son terme
l'opposition elle se donne jusqu'à
demain ont riposté par une éventuelle
motion de censure
une fois de plus en tout cas l'assemblée
accouche au forceps d'une nouvelle loi
sur l'audiovisuel et en politique
toujours l'élection législative
partielle de bordeaux talence pour
remplacer madame catherine lalumière
après le premier tour il ya ballottage
un ballotage favorable aux représentants
du parti socialiste claude baron qui
devance de 13 voix seulement
notre camarade noël mamère qui lui
représenter la majorité présidentielle
mais en dehors des partis au deuxième
tour monsieur barande devrait s'imposer
face au candidat de l'opposition gérard
castagnède à document étonnant dans le
magazine médical tout à l'heure sur
antenne 2 henri sannier et jean daniel
flaysakier consacrent leurs magazines à
la forme sous toutes ses formes c'est
d'actualité juste avant les vacances et
vous pourrez voir notamment ce reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux dans une
clinique en suisse une de ces cliniques
où depuis des années on prétend proposer
des cures de rajeunissement et la base
des ailes voir on y fait de bien
curieuses l'injection alain labouze jean
corneille reportage côté cour les
traditionnels blouses blanches et des
méthodes de soins aujourd'hui interdite
en france
côté jardin un troupeau de 600 moutons
noirs
nous sommes dans une clinique en suisse
où l'on propose pour environ 40000
francs français des injections très
spécial avec des cellules fraîche de
foetus de moutons plus étonnant encore
c'est le professeur barnard le célèbre
chirurgien du coeur qui après trois
cures de cellules vente maintenant les
mérites de la méthode
dans un document vidéo pour les nouveaux
arrivants
au gagnant quel âge avez-vous 70 ans
j'ai soixante saison nous attendons de
nous sentir mieux à nouveau nous
espérons vieillir plus lentement que la
vieillesse viennoise immoral chute
explora avec les cellules fraîche de
foetus de moutons ce serait donc la fin
de la fatigue des pertes de mémoire des
baisse de libido bref l'armé absolue
contre tous les effets du vieillissement
est ce que c'est des cures de
rajeunissement que vous proposez là un
drôle de question posée là parce que
vous savez très bien trop change pas
l'âge déjà cette revitalisation
pourtant il n'y a aucun argument
scientifique à l'appui de cette méthode
alors revitaliser à tout prix d'accord
mais est-ce que ça sert vraiment à
quelque chose et si vous voulez savoir
quels sont les personnalités notamment
du monde politique et les personnalités
importantes qui ont suivi ces cures de
rajeunissement
il y en a beaucoup et bien vous regardez
le magazine comment ça va une d'henri
sannier c'est à 22h15 juste après
l'heure de vérité avec michel noir
l'heure de vérité de françois et durieux
la dernière édition ce sera aussitôt
après le magazine médical christian mary
mono donc vers minuit bonne soirée sur
antenne 2 mais tout de suite bien sûr la
météo avec laurent cabrol excellente
soirée à demain 20 heures